sometimes people ask me did you think
this was the type of experiment that
would win a Nobel Prize and I can
honestly say that I wasn't thinking
about prizes or anything I was more
excited about the experiment one might
ask the question why would someone
interest in in developmental biology in
genetics how did I introduce wind up
being the person that introduced this
very useful tool into biology and I
don't have a very good answer to that
other than the fact I was just excited
when I heard that first seminar about
GFP and realized it would be a very very
useful tool and I thought it would be a
lot of fun if we did those experiments I
think that's actually a very important
part of science is that we're always
working on the edge of what we know
interesting aspects Marlys
sociologically than anything else for me
has been to see how this rather simple
experiment of putting GFP into bacteria
and worms has expanded as everyone else
has added their thoughts and ideas to
using this protein it was estimated in
2014 by the people at chemistry
abstracts that in the 20 years since our
paper was published that there have been
on the order of a hundred and sixty
thousand scientific papers using
fluorescent proteins and the sheer range
of the things that people have tried
thought of has been really remarkable
that first day when I was listening to a
seminar where I first learned about GFP
I thought about some experiments that I
would like to do but my ideas have been
dwarfed by all the really incredible
ideas that people have had coming out of
this we're not trying to duplicate
things that we already know that doesn't
give us more information we're trying to
understand something new
we're not all that great at
understanding things that are new so
it's not maybe a surprise that
experiments don't work but we keep
trying to go after it and once we do
have those discoveries and those
breakthroughs it's exceptionally
rewarding
you